spring and Ben Shapiro editor-in-chief
of daily wired a constant and candid
columnist host of the Ben Shapiro shows
great podcast Ben in addition to this
thing passing last night first in the
Senate and then in the house in the five
o'clock hour today Bette Midler tweeted
out after Rand Paul had his little
filibuster said where's Rand Paul's
neighbor when you need him
what do you think about a class act and
the initiate yeah first of all has been
Midler been relevant since like beaches
in 1988 when I was four she's still
around and talking about things and why
we care I guess she was in Hello Dolly
or something but hey Rand Paul just on
the substance is exactly correct
I mean the fact is that Republicans
spent years railing against Obama
deficits and Democratic deficits in brew
now they have power again and they just
spent an enormous sum of money and I
understand they wanted to remove
sequestration on the military but they
touted that same sequestration is a big
win in 2011 I was there I was I remember
and so do you and and so the idea that
we have to blow out the budget with a
Republican majority in both houses just
demonstrates it once again that in the
end the American people are really
inconsistent about spending on the one
hand they say they want cuts to spending
on the other hand the minute anyone
proposes a specific cuts of spending the
American people start to get very upset
about it and both parties tend to buckle
to that rather than educating the public
what what are the implications of this
deal then Ben because you know a lot of
people did want that military spending
that has been hit by sequestration but
when it comes to debt and deficits what
is this gonna mean I mean it's just
gonna mean a continuation of deficits
out til the end of time we're gonna be
looking at 30 trillion dollar debts in
in the near future and a lot of this has
to do with the fact that nobody wants to
talk about the real drivers of the debt
and that's not military spending at all
the real driver of the debt of Social
Security Medicare Medicaid that
represents about 60 percent of the
american federal budget the american
military budget is somewhere between 18
and 20 percent so the idea that if we
raise the military spending that this is
somehow the great driver of the deficit
is not true i just don't understand why
republicans can't make that case let's
have our military spending and let's
talk about restructuring some of the
real issues in the economy Social
Security's been in the red since 2010
I'm not gonna see any of the money I'm
putting into Social Security
all right you also want to happen we
want to ask you about these text
messages between those lovers at the FBI
apparently they don't like the pro-life
March because it ties up traffic and for
other reasons
this was some of the text exchanged back
in January of 2016
he says struck says blanking marchers
making traffic problems she writes back
I truly hate these people no support for
the woman who actually has to spend the
rest of her life rearing this child but
we care about life and then she says
a-holes well I mean they're classy
couple you couldn't tell from the
earlier text messages they really ought
to be on the cover of GQ just these are
these are the leading figures in
American public life the only question
that really matters in the end for Paige
and struck the only reason we even care
about them is to what extent their
political biases ended up making a
difference in terms of their bias and in
the in the investigation into Hillary
Clinton and the investigation into
suppose it Trump Russia collusion of
which there's no evidence to this point
now you know we'll have to see what what
what the rest of the investigation shows
is why we have a House Intelligence
Committee this is why we have a House
Oversight Committee but it always didn't
good when you have FBI agents who have
this sort of obvious political bias
texting with one another about how much
they hate particular segments of the
American population you got to figure
though bend that it's a good thing that
this Michael Horowitz who's the
Inspector General over at the Department
of Justice that he's also looking into
things because he's the reason they're
not on Muller's team anymore he's also
apparently the reason that Andrew McCabe
who is like the number two guy at the
FBI he's out because of sounds like
animus against the president the the
level of bureaucratic incompetence and
corruption the level of political bias
inside of our intelligence agencies
there's a reason the American people
don't trust these agencies and it's not
just because President Trump has been
railing against them it's because these
agencies acted in non trustworthy ways
during the last election cycle with
regard to Hillary Clinton and the
American people are seeing that with
each and every breaking story so it's a
good thing that there are some folks who
are attempting to ferret this stuff out
but there is gonna have to be a
cleansing process that takes place
whether it's by President Trump or
whether it's by you know members of the
of the DOJ and FBI themselves something
has to be done to restore the trust of
the American people here then so the
budget deal was struck meant to sort of
clear that clear the decks for a deal on
the president's wall and border security
in exchange potential
for pathway to citizenship for so-called
dreamers daca recipients well a couple
of dreamers have come out publicly and
said that if they're not allowed to stay
legally after the March 5th deadline
they're gonna basically self-deport and
leave the US if a deal isn't reached
what do you make of that do they want to
stay or go oh well I mean I'm sort of
confused by the strategy here I guess
they're trying to blackmail people who
want to deport them with the threat that
they will self-deport which doesn't make
a whole hell of a lot of sense but yeah
I guess the real answer is they're
trying to blackmail Democrats they're
trying to suggest to Democrats the
Democrats don't care enough about daca
recipients so watching the internecine
warfare between potential daca
recipients and dreamers and the
democratic party that claims to speak
for them is sort of amusing all right
it's always a pleasure Ben Shapiro
joining us live today check out his
podcast by the same name sir thank you
very much thank you